my name is helen lurie
and i design radios on electronics for a
really tiny spacecraft
and um
how tiny is tiny oh how tiny um well
you're basically limited by some aspect
of
responsibility to other people in space
which is
as long as you can be power positive and
can control your satellite enough to
avoid
collisions you can make it arbitrarily
small
aside from that as long as those
constraints are met
i typically work in what's called the
cubesat environment
which is about 30 centimeters by 10 by
10 and then unforable solar panels will
make it more like a meter across
but in package form it's about a bread
box
smaller
okay so why space um
it's got a really good location and
location is everything here
there's a lot of applications you know
for geo you do broadcast because
broadcasting radio signals from space is
actually cheaper
than digging up all the dirt in canada
and running fiber all across
all that lone lone tundra all over the
place so instead you just put one geo
bird up which is kind of
kind of crazy think about that a billion
dollars is cheaper than that but yeah
digging uh digging george is really
expensive internet for ships
the arctic um
mio it's a little bit closer i'll have a
plot of the distances from the earth but
that's medium earth orbit it's a little
bit below geo
again you still do communications from
that you can just
space physics and the gps satellites are
up there which we all use
and leo is mostly the playground where
i play in and there's a lot of things
about leo that make it easier to
start innovating in it and to
start doing low-cost manufacturing
techniques that you can't quite
get away with in jail again
communications spying on people on the
earth i don't work for any sort of
military so i don't spy on people
uh earth exploration ship tracking plane
tracking like the recent malaysia
uh la um not launch uh airplane that
went down there were satellites that
were listening to those signals for
example
um uh laser comms research
uh photography so uh
this is a little bit small to see but
i think we can do this do you see the
earth and right next to it
is the little blue line that's where leo
is so it's really really close to earth
and then green is mio you want a pointer
uh oh i think we can just do colors
um and geo or if you have one
i can do it all right that might help no
you don't have it
okay that's fine i can just point and
just flail my hands wildly at the screen
ah schmancy thank you
oh let's see huh look at that
okay um and geo
is really really far away um it's
actually off this chart
um a little bit it's
35 000 kilometers away so
uh being up there there's a lot of
constraints
um like the space environment uh
stuff is really really far away so
there's signal latency issues so normal
tcp won't work
if you're trying to connect up to your
satellite because one side is waiting
for an act and the other
side hasn't even gotten the packet yet
before you time out
the other big thing is like you have no
physical access to it so if you push a
software
bootload to your satellite and it causes
the default state of your satellite to
go into like a non-listening mode
you have lost contact and you will never
regain contact again you cannot set an
intern to go
flip switch on the server so whatever
you do
whenever you do a design technique you
always have to have a safe state that
the satellite will
go back to if it hasn't heard from
anybody in a while
vacuum you get things like multi-paction
fans don't work well for cooling um
it's like everything's covered in a down
blanket
and solder whiskering so multipacking is
kind of a
fun thing we don't really run into it in
leo
but when you have a big wave guide
and you have photons or electric fields
however you want to think about the
universe
going down this thing if there are
certain power levels that are strong
enough
and the frequencies of oscillation of
the signals match up with the dimensions
of the waveguide just right
then as the electric field energizes
electrons on the top side of the
waveguide
and causes them to shoot out they'll
reach the bottom just about the time
that the potential energy is flipped the
other way these electrons get
get ejected also so you get this rising
wave of electrons going back and forth
and welding the
waveguide shut or damaging in some way
if any of the conditions are not met
like your signal is not strong enough or
your waveguide's not quite the right
size for this to happen it won't
we don't have to worry about this in leo
because we don't tend to run like
60 watt traveling wave tube amplifiers
like they do at lorell
so what else uh you always want to use
leaded solder
it's a little bit better for a lot of
things solder won't
whisker as much if it's got lead in it
and so this actually runs into
using off-the-shelf chips because they
all tend to be cots compliant
on that cots or coht whatever the um
the lead uh compliance temperature
changes
your satellite will go through minus 25
to plus 50 degrees and this depends on
your orbit this depends on the time of
year
this depends on your size but in leo we
see these kinds of temperatures in geo
they can be more extreme
so a practical thing is you want to use
tcxos temperature
compensated crystal oscillators instead
of just an oscillator for your clock
a geostationary satellite we use an
ovenized crystal so that that's like a
big box that's constantly keeping the
entire crystal
at warmer than it would ever get too
naturally
and so it can always keep it from
getting colder
there's a lot of problems with using
ovenized crystals
first of all they tend to be like this
big or you can get them a little bit
smaller
and the other thing is they take a long
time to warm up and while they're
actively warming
the crystals frequency is drifting all
over the place and so that means your
radio center frequency is drifting all
over the place
so that means you have to keep them on
all the time in leo we can't afford the
power
so we cut corners this is the first
corner we're cutting tcxos
and they're good enough and they're not
too expensive
you want to test everything in a thermal
oven so you cycle it
preferably a thermal vacuum oven so that
your spacecraft will actually experience
the vacuum and so heat buildup will
happen as expected
debris occasionally your satellite runs
into things at three kilometers per
second
or your satellite will uh
either its fault or somebody else's
fault maybe it's a piece of debris maybe
your satellites lost control
you tend to sign up for these air force
email announcements uh there's uh
there's a
government entity that tracks every
single object bigger than like i don't
know posted stamp or a couple of postage
stamps up there
and you'll get these email alerts and
i've gotten them a few times they're
quite worrisome like you know
dear so and so you are registered as an
administrator of object
you know you are eminent for an upcoming
collision and you know one week with
this other object
and so you get on the phones and you
start scrambling calling the other
operator
and seeing who's going to steer out of
the way if it's looking like it's still
going to happen
so there's a lot of radiation up there
also and particles flying all over the
place
leo is a lot easier than geo you tend to
be protected very strongly you're closer
to the earth
and you have convenient magnetic fields
that are deflecting a lot of crap that
you don't want hitting your electronics
and so we can cut corners because we're
closer to earth that you can't do in geo
so some parts of the stock
are not exactly applicable to doing
low-cost engineering up there
there's a lot of regulations itu know i
know
fcc everybody wants a piece of the pie
so
noah cares about debris
so if your satellite when it breaks
apart upon re-entry
is going to actually hit with a big
chunk somebody
you need to register that basically you
need to
get a license showing that your
satellite will burn up that you've done
the analysis
as you're going through the atmosphere
the fcc
they care about frequency allocation if
everybody just grabbed however much
bandwidth the frequency they wanted all
the time then
there would be none left over at least
that's the theory so you have to
register
in advance and pay huge bonds and filing
fees
in order to be able to operate
anybody can reach your satellite via
radio the bandwidths
and the center frequencies are all
public knowledge so
if you don't secure your links
somebody's going to figure out what your
modulation scheme is and they're going
to crack it open if they want
or start bouncing signals off of it
we've seen that happen already
people just commandeering other people's
transponder channels
on the other hand space is easy users
can't drop your satellite into a toilet
there's no dogs or kittens chewing on
your electronics
no security vulnerabilities due to
physical access
no humidity and there's very little
atmosphere so stuff doesn't rust
and there's very low drag there's not a
lot of rf attenuation the entire
time the signal is propagating until it
hits the atmosphere it's only doing
the uh range loss due to the electric
fields
spreading but it's not actually being
you know hitting water molecules and
oscillating and transferring energy to
them or scattering
which is what signals on you know the
planet's surface uh do
and so this is actually quite
interesting because we can use texas
instruments
little ism band chips that are rated for
if you're actually doing like wimax or
you know wi-fi or something like that on
them they're rated for like you know i
don't know 50 meters 100 meters
and all of a sudden you put a power
amplifier in front of them and you try
to talk to space and you can
because the uh s-pen radiation isn't
busy heating up the arrow along the way
and bouncing off of things and and these
kind of environments are really complex
to deal with for electronics because
there's there's emi and signals bouncing
all over the place up there it's pretty
quiet
um you can get a lot of sun and your
solar panels don't get covered in dust
in los angeles you look at a solar panel
we put them up on the roof of spacex
and these things were producing
basically no power at all after a few
months because they had gotten caked
with like
a thing of this greasy grime that you
could just run your finger on and just
pick up palpable
disgusting black goop you know just
hawthorne air pollution
up there solar panels stay pretty
pristine um
and you don't have to cut corners on
every five cents of your design when
you're designing
an iphone you can bet that they care
about every five
five cents for space you start cutting
corners on every fifty dollars
or if you're building a geo bird maybe
start cutting corners on every four
hundred dollars but you don't have to
worry about five cents if you want to
buy a nicer capacitor
that costs like you know eight extra
cents off of digi-key it's okay you can
splurge
and i think the security vulnerabilities
question
only a temporal thing right now probably
that's true
because certainly the soviets did
actually
look seriously at weaponization of their
various spacecraft
but i'm surprised how do we left off
your routine well not to the degree that
the soviets did though
um yeah so
zero g in a lot of ways uh helps
one example is you can get away with
using
springs they're a little bit too weak
like if you try to deploy your small
solar arrays
on the earth down here it'll be kind of
saggy a little bit but up there they
won't they'll be nice and straight
and so things like that so
i mean the satellite that i launched
okay now let me finish the satellite
i had one of my bosses was
he was hoping that it was going to blow
up on the launch pad because we had no
we were flying the largest antenna ever
flown
uh it's more than that let's go go ahead
though
okay um right next
so how do you get to space by adding a
lot of megajoules of energy
both potential and kinetic
and rockets are pretty expensive if
you're trying to get to leo
you're looking to shell you know at
least 10k per kilogram and geo it's more
like 27 k per kilogram
and so this leads to some fun
engineering replacing every
quarter inch 20 steel bolt with titanium
saves you 50 dollars per bolt to leo
because the bolt increases in price i
have the exact numbers here here you go
it's 150 bucks to launch a single bolt
but you cut the weight in half but
titanium costs more
so you end up saving 50. so you can do
the math there
and rockets are pretty harsh
environments to be on
you have vibration shock and acoustic
we'd find these dead coconut crabs on
omalek after every falcon 1 launch
killed by the acoustic wave coming off
of the rocket as it lifts off
and because the engines are on
how do you grab a rocket you're a small
person you're trying to do small leo
satellites you can't just like
call up spacex and go i'd like a falcon
9 now
if if you are you know um intelsat and
you're putting up a big geo bird you can
just
commission an entire launch vehicle
which means you have bought the ride
completely you control where it goes you
have
prime you know mechanical considerations
everything for you
but that costs a lot of money and you
have to pay a lot of insurance to get up
there
so writing as a secondary opens up
opportunities for low-cost satellite
builders let me just check the time 436
okay
there's a lot of entities like the
university of toronto and isis
that are organizing uh launches uh
for you as a secondary so if you have a
small satellite maybe yay or maybe yay
big
they'll find another launch where
there's room inside of the fairing
so the primary is in there you know and
they've already seated it mechanically
but there's all this room along the
edges
and so after the primary is ejected
there's these secondaries living in
these things called pea pods i'll show
you a pea pod later
that are ready to deploy later
oh test flights of new rockets are
another good thing i remember on falcon
flight 3 we killed i think some
some number of student cubesats that
were hoping to get to space cheap on
that launch but
unfortunately it failed
there's different ways of solving the
constraints
so for l'oreal
um which is is uh
one example of sort of old reliable
traditional space
um satellites cost several hundreds of
millions
sorry um
uh and because of this
uh this huge price tag and because of
the huge market that's behind it by the
way somebody who's willing to shell out
this much money for a satellite has a
huge billion dollar market behind them
there's a ratcheting process on the cost
and the amount of testing
well it's like well because every
satellite costs so much might as well
spend 500
on a harness you know on just the
connector for a harness to make it super
i don't know emi wonderful
and because the customers already spent
so much they're going to push you as
hard as they can to do another test to
chase down
0.3 decibels of power difference here or
there so they're going to stop the
entire operation
backtrack and you have to reset up
everything and test to find these measly
measly small amounts but it's important
to them because there's so much money
riding on the situation
the development cycle is pretty old and
ordering parts if you're trying to be a
small person entering this field is
basically impossible
ordering these traveling wave tube
amplifiers that they're using
like the lead times are long the costs
are huge
and you can't just buy one so um
is that why you need such expensive
amplifiers or why are there that's a
couple of things
one they're super reliable the stuff
that you buy
that's like rated for geostationary
satellites
is bulletproof it will never fail from
radiation it's got all these you know
checksums and fault tolerances on the
inside the cases are like
thick thick thick milled metal they're
sealed off and gasketized completely the
workmanship on these things is fantastic
they will last in space for about 20
years
and yes the the energies because you're
so far away from earth
you need really really high radio signal
powers in order to actually reach your
users or reach the ground station
and because the costs are so high you
often don't have an engineering unit so
you're trying to debug your satellite
which isn't working
and you sometimes don't have access to
an engineering unit that you can just
like
tinker around with and take apart with a
saw and re-solder a new
you know inductor on it to try to figure
out what's happening
you're just trying to debug it kind of
in the air and maybe if you get your
hands on an engineering unit you can't
destroy it because it's probably the
only one
spacex did things a little bit
differently rockets cost a lot less
money there
the development cycle is really really
short
these people are changing falcon 9 every
time it launches they have never
launched the same rocket twice
it is always going through revisions um
i mean i don't know if every time but
that is just the the company culture is
to change and innovate
every single time and ordering parts
is um you know you just kind of get on
the phone with
your vendor it's like delivery time is
about two months after receipt of order
and you have an extra couple units lying
around in your lab bench that are for
destruction and testing
so it's a lot easier to innovate quickly
in an environment like that
and then there's alt space which is the
cubesat world
this is like planet labs and nanosatisfy
both up in the city this is a canopus
systems over at nasa
ames again the development time is
really short
you get your chips on order from digikey
you
just use a 10 molex flat mount connector
ribbon cables are your friends
you get your pcbs printed at sierra
proto express
in sunnyvale and they come back to you
in about a week you
assemble them all by hand a set of
flight boards cost you about 1.5 k
i can break down the cost and i will
later but roughly you know getting
high frequency rf material printed on a
pcb
for a run of 16 boards is going to cost
you under 3 000
that's just for the pcbs and then the
parts
uh to populate all 16 of those are gonna
cost you another
i don't know four thousand five thousand
dollars in chips maybe less
so you're looking at the whole thing is
like eight thousand dollars plus
assembly
and you have 16 radios out of that um
because they're so cheap you basically
have like six engineering units for
every single launch just lying around on
the table and you're taking these things
apart and you have a soldering iron
and we used to have a planet labs
what was called the electronics cemetery
up on the wall
and so there'd be so it's at electronic
cemetery and then there was all these
esd bags with
the dead electronics in question and the
cause of death written on the little
post-it note
with its name and the serial number
stapled up there so people go like how
did we break that expand transceiver
let's go
pull it off oh yeah i remember the cause
of death is written right here on the
post-it note and the board's right there
you can take it out and re-examine
what is it that you did wrong last time
and it's also kind of a joke also
alluding to the fact that it's okay to
just fry stuff and destroy stuff like
there's like
smokes and curses coming from people's
lab benches all the time and
it's okay because stuff doesn't cost a
lot
and um at least uh
in the companies i've experienced here
you continue to rev the boards
constantly and you launch what you've
got this is what most of these people in
this field are doing they're just
continuously revisioning
so why can we do low cost satellites now
check the time really quick 4 40. okay
oh look at that i don't have to tell
everybody what like my mental state is i
just concept they're all subtle like
thank you
all right um so what led to the
low-cost satellite revolution part of it
was the invention
of the cubesat buzz format and the
invention of the p-pod which is a
standardized deployer
for small satellites let me jump ahead
really quick to show you a pea pod
um this is a three uke uh
cubesat deployer uh 3u is a is
you know how in racks there's a you know
a 1u rack unit which is like 1.5 inches
tall 28 inches across or whatever
and satellites speak this is a 10
centimeter by 10 centimeter by 10
centimeter block at least when it's
folded up you can have whatever you want
unfurl from
antennas and solar panels later but when
it's on the launch
site it must fit into a third of this
that's a 1u unit you can have a 2u
satellite
you can have a 3u you can have any
combination of those things between
different
uh clients all running together in the
same deployer and they'll just get sput
out in order
this lid pops open and there's a spring
down here
on a piece of metal basically and it
just
shoves and there's latches on the inside
that keep satellites from
breaking out until it's their turn so if
you have three different satellites
um the second one will have a latch
holding it in place even when the first
one is being pushed out after the door
opens and then that latch
uh burns and it goes out
um also moore's law really helped
even though 10 000 dollars per kilogram
is still a lot moore's law says you can
do a lot more of one kilogram
than you could do with one kilogram 20
years ago
the computational speed you can have up
there the digital cameras
the radio chips it's amazing how easy
and simple and fast stuff is to develop
now
higher precision manufacturing leads to
more radiation tolerant components but
there's a huge caveat here which is the
junction sizes are getting smaller and
that actually makes things more
susceptible
on the other hand because they weigh a
lot less and they're a lot smaller you
can afford to spend more volume
and space shielding them and various
groups have done
uh studies of how much shielding do you
need in leo and if you're looking for
about a two-year
orbit because probably in two years
moore's law has made your current
satellite obsolete so you might as well
replace it because it's all
fairly inexpensive also you're decaying
quite a bit more rapidly in leo there is
a little bit of atmosphere so your
satellite is still hitting the
occasional speck of air
here and there and here and there which
is slowing it down so
if you want about a two-year life span
you need about
three millimeters of aluminium shielding
that's not a lot it's not terrible
if you have that all along the outside
the stuff on the inside is reasonably
tolerant it'll still get
occasional upset so you still need to
have watchdogs monitoring the state of
your components and flipping power on
them back and forth if they don't reply
but um they probably won't have horrible
horrible damage in under two years
older than nanosense um
uh well we are trying and and and and it
does work that way actually
like here's an example um you know uh
i remember worrying so much about
mechanical strength for the big
components i was integrating at spacex
right because everything
is always going to be on a rocket it's
always being shooken
and sloshed and it's cold or it's hot
and
it's just it's not a very comfortable
place goldilocks would refuse to ride up
there
but we had to worry about things you
know all their torque moments and how
they're going to crack the swear in
another way
satellites when they're really really
really small and you're designing the
pcbs and you don't have heavy
you know vacuum tubes on them causing a
whole bunch of like mass to be sloshing
around
and all you have is a t9 chip it makes
the mechanical integration a lot easier
because your pcb has no weight on it
it's probably not going to break as long
as it's in a good frame
all your um ongoing bases or
um you should
but you don't but we don't um
you kind of just do it on orbit but you
can
and there are entities that do and one
useful way of doing it is if you have
access to a particle collider
great so if you know of a research
institute that has one
you can accelerate particles up to the
correct energies and hit your boards
with it
there's a pretty good easy cheat which
is that there are
irradiation facilities located anywhere
where there's dairy farms the closest
ones around here
are in gilroy and they have a
cobalt 60 source which
basically it's a big chamber and inside
of the big chamber there's a smaller
chamber inside of the small chamber
there's a mechanical deployment
mechanism where the cobalt 60 can hide
inside of the inner leaded chamber
meanwhile you wheel in your big racks
stacked with eggs
or milk or whatever it is that you want
to fry and
you tuck them in there close the outer
door and then the cobalt 60 comes out
you can do the same thing for satellites
you can basically rent out one of these
chambers for a couple of night times on
their off shift and pop your satellite
in there
it doesn't give you quite the same
distribution of energies that you'd like
and it's not all the different kinds of
particles but it'll give you some idea
that's an inexpensive way and again a
particle accelerator will give you the
complete spread of all the different
types of you know
nuclei and photons and you know whatever
else that you want
um yes i think we covered that slide
there's the pea pod again the lovely
peapod um
so i've built mostly satellites which
take this whole thing up
yeah but you can build a build smaller
this is what three cubesats look popping
out of a peapod deployer so you can see
it's one two three one after the other
these were released by the international
space station
fairly recently a few months ago or in
the last year sometime
fairly pretty picture it looks like
these guys either they don't have any
sort of deployable solar panels you can
see they're lined with solar panels
on the outside or maybe the people on
the ground will wait to give signals to
deploy things later on when they're a
little bit more spread out from each
other because you can see they're pretty
close right now
like about 15 centimeters apart
so what is the state-of-the-art nanosat
nanosatellite
what are we doing there this is a
picture of a recent planet labs launch
coming out of the deployer again on the
international space station
these are uh 3u
so they were inside of a peapod style
deployer in here
and you can see that the lid popped up
already on this one
it was just being held up there by that
lid being closed and so it already has
something deployed
but more stuff will come out later
so this is a picture of a whole bunch
i guess the the photograph's pretty
artistic and close in but
it's a picture of a whole bunch of them
they just have you know 30 or 40
satellites lying out on the lab bench so
if you really need to test one you just
grab one market as an engineering unit
now not for
you know not for human consumption or
not for launch and
just start playing with it most
everything was developed in house there
and we made everything happen
to the time of the first launch in under
two years from design
iteration and to the first huge flock
launching earlier this year
this is a picture that steve of
what is it dfj dfw whatever that
vc firm that back planet labs uh took of
us
this is you guys recognize this here
this is the dish on top of the hill
and uh i was the operator for this and
so
first a couple of satellites were just
coming up we had no idea if they were
gonna work but we just you know powered
on the dish and we had our radios there
and we managed to reach our satellites
okay and everything worked
um this dish by the way is awful to
operate has anybody here had to steer
this thing
it's horrible if you like you give it
huh it is it it it's not only ancient
but it's like some sort of old
missile turret or anti-missile gun or
something
yeah we uh we once accidentally entered
a
so you enter these configuration files
for this dish that have like a time step
and then the new azim with an elevation
timestep new azimuth
elevation and the software which runs in
dos on this thing doesn't uh
quite check the coordinates so if you
happen to maybe
reach the end of the file and not have
the correct and the file delimiter in
there or something and it tries to go
back
in one time step to the beginning it
will try
and because it used to be like some sort
of huge anti-military missile gun
this whole thing just starts it's scary
how fast this thing can accelerate and
turn it's insane
so i remember having to go like exit
exit exit stop
uh when that happened huh with the hand
on the circuit breaker
yes
and uh so this is a picture that
we got down from space uh at planet labs
using the high data rate x-band radio
that i designed all in-house
and we were able to transfer fairly high
resolution images down
a lot of them also i can't tell you
exact data rates
or can i is that on the fcc application
if you're interested go check the fcc
application whatever is public knowledge
about them you can find there
so what are some rules for building
state of the art
space radios or really any sort of
electronics
it really helps that you are so
inexperienced that you don't know x-band
doesn't fit inside of a cubesat
it really helps that you don't know
what's not possible because i didn't
know it was impossible and so therefore
it worked um
but my my manager at planet labs very uh
carefully did not tell me that when he
was at a conference somebody said what
you guys are trying to do expand
communications and cubesat that'll never
work
and so he just did not relay that over
to me and so i didn't know
you just use off-the-shelf chips from
digikey
there are companies that are making
amazing
transceiver modules and power amplifiers
that are just teeny tiny surface mount
chips
you can just get them stocked off of
digi-keys companies like analog
and texas instruments and linear and
hittite that are just doing amazing
stuff all the way up to k-band
if you use a software-defined front-ends
then you can continue to leverage
new packet protocols and forward error
correction schemes as they come out
and so you don't have to relaunch a new
satellite in order to gain new software
functionality
but again back to the proximity issue
you need to make sure that whenever you
push a new software image up to your
satellite
that it's not going to break the current
behavior so you always have to have some
safe state but you can push something up
but into another memory slot you're in
the safe state and then you
try the new software image if it works
then you keep it if it doesn't you just
go back to the safe state and report
that to the ground
let's see
um i can't tell you exactly what any
particular company is doing
um but you want a fairly real-time
robust operating system that developers
that you pull off the streets in san
francisco know how to develop for
yeah um almost uniformly
people choose linux as to what
particular flavor you have to do your
research
but that is a very good os it's not
completely real time but it's better
than windows
anyway you don't want to be running
windows in space that would just be a
really scary thing to do
let's see
i'll go into the modularity okay so i
actually wanted to go into eagle right
now
and show you guys uh the radios we're
currently designing
for bitbeam technologies this is the
gerber files for it
um we are leveraging off-the-shelf chips
from texas instruments
to use as the transceivers these are ism
banned
transceiver units so they receive and
send they're running 8051
microcontrollers on the inside and it's
all integrated with the rf circuitry
all we have to add to the front of that
is uh
so for fault tolerance here basically
we've placed
a high data rate mcu that can talk up to
two megabit per second and speed
and a low data rate mcu and everything
is broken out to these connectors which
basically bring the usb out to the
flight computer
and here if one of your mcs goes down
either permanent uh damage due to
radiation or something else or just
it won't power up you can just switch
over to the other one and also you have
the two different ones for different
data rates they overlap over some
range of speeds and we had to add a
front end
uh this is a chip from avago it's a 2.5
watt power amplifier
this is a driver amplifier for it this
is the
footprint for a faraday cage to shield a
front end because you don't want stray
photons getting in there from
the rest of your electronics usb by the
way is really really noisy
that that stuff radiates all over the
place like there are you know all the
usb chip manufacturers they all
have fcc rules that they have to abide
by and i guess whatever those rules are
they're fairly loose by my standards
they work for a computer case or for a
laptop but like they're awful when
you're trying to
operate in a nano satellite where like
the next pcb is like a centimeter away
from those usb lines
and so to prevent that kind of stuff in
a really small
format we use a six layer stack up the
top layer is a high frequency
rf material the bottom layers are all
fr4 because a
it's cheap and b it's structurally sound
you have copper fill
on all the layers to block emi you
staple your vias
your power planes shut with vias i'm not
showing that happening on this board i
think i have those disabled
there's power planes on the inside
layers here
and they're all blocked off with ground
fill from every other power plane
and data lines have to run on their own
planes so that they don't radiate
um this is how we get by with not having
the radio inside of a big
milled aluminium case which would block
its emi we're just
trying to do it on the board level
because that's fairly light
so that was that i have to find the
other presentation where to go
okay
so um manufacturing costs if you're
trying to do low-cost uh satellite
construction so you're just doing the
pcb
layer um you're not doing big fancy
cases you're doing fairly inexpensive
connectors you're just
soldering on little ribbon cables or
just wires
these are some costs that i have kept
track of
from developing our own line of radios
with just one other co-founder
boards are about three thousand dollars
all the test equipment was under ten
thousand dollars
and assembly is a thousand with four day
turn time and uh one thing i forgot to
add here is the
cost of the bill of materials of the
radio which is another three and a half
thousand for this design
for 16 units it is fairly fairly cheap
to get started
on hacking your own electronics in your
own bedroom lab
for 16 boards so basically
one thing to note about pcbs getting
done is they have a minimum
size that they run through the machine
so if you want one or you want 20
as long as you can fit 20 on one panel
it's about the same price
more or less it's kind of the same thing
once the machine is set up to do all the
etching and the drilling then
it doesn't they don't care how big it is
oh uh the electronics um
yeah um that was for all 16 also
like as an example one uh 2.5 watt
consumer s-band power amplifier
uh is gonna and and with 42 power rider
deficiency i might add which is really
fantastic
which means you're dumping less heat and
consuming less solar panel power
um that thing costs 16 from digikey
um if i was buying some sort of space
rated component i
i don't even know i haven't even gotten
quotes i mean it would be five hundred
dollars six hundred dollars
i've seen ovenized uh crystals on sale
at the cubesat conference for over a
thousand dollars for one crystal
i have three crystals uh on that design
that i showed you guys
and uh the most expensive one was i
think about 40 for really really nice
low phase noise like amazing rf
characteristics temperature compensated
design
i'll go into that in a bit i want to uh
go through an interesting way that we're
trying to solve
one particular aspect of spacecraft
design which tends to be hard which is
radios so
because the fcc has split apart the
spectrum
and they have certain bands for certain
types of operations for certain types of
satellites
it probably means that there's nobody
making an off-the-shelf radio that
matches your application for your
satellite for your exact data rates for
your exact antenna which is why people
tend to end up commissioning these
things
semi-custom or fully custom from some
third party
and so you're talking about paying for
somebody's complete development cycle
paying a team of programmers to design a
new packet protocol
for you if you are a company like laurel
that's been in the business for a long
time
and your satellites tend to be fairly
similar from time to time you can reduce
a lot of these costs by buying the same
kinds of things over and over again
but if you're trying to innovate and
build new types of small satellites
you can't do that so one thing that
we're trying to do to solve that is to
design an extremely modular radio system
so what i showed you guys there that is
a prototype
model of the motherboard um but
by uh using the same exact uh
software front ends um i guess i can
flip over to it
so on this design you have your software
front end with you know all of your data
lines coming out
and these mcus on here and they're all
using
one radio section which means that you
can only put out
the same amount of wattage i mean you
can de-bias your amplifier but you're
kind of limited to certain range
if a certain you know band that your
loner's amplifier is optimized over so
you can pretty much only use this design
over s-band
but by changing a lot of things by
taking the rf
off of the motherboard and putting in
drill holes instead
with snap-on coaxial connectors we can
use the exact same software-defined
front-end and pop-on
band modules pop on ku band modules pop
on x-band modules
so if a particular person once said i
want
two watts of c-band power for transmit
and i'd like to receive at vhf
you just pop on those modules onto the
exact same motherboard and they just sit
into uh
vias that you just solder them in or
screw them on you can almost
instantaneously spin up radios spanning
about with this
type of design we're looking to span
about 12 gigahertz of frequency range
all the way from
vhf up to ku band everything is going to
use high frequency connectors
it's not worth having the cost savings
of using low frequency components
because then you have to keep track of
different types of inventory and you
have to keep track of different types of
boards
so everything uses ku band design
techniques and ku band coplanar wave
guide
and smp are really really nice
board mount connectors that can pass up
to 40 gigahertz and rf frequency and
they're really tiny and they have
pretty good power handling
characteristics we are looking to reduce
uh the cost of spacecraft radios for
semi-custom build
except the the software front end you
know you can either recycle the same one
or you can use a different one
down to about six thousand dollars
starting from scratch
to get the kind of radio you want down
from development cycles of paying some
third party you know 100 000
or whatever it is to design this for you
by just having these different daughter
boards
and popping them on there
one thing that's pretty cool about our
design is that
uh we found this one chip i won't tell
you who it's from
kind of secret saucy but um it will
just directly turn a digital signal into
an rf signal up to a certain band it'll
just directly synthesize
radio for you and also do the same thing
in the reverse direction it'll take
radio
up to a certain frequency and turn it
into bits on the back plane
and this thing just speaks high speed
lvds lines on the back end
and you just plug them into an fpga
which can then process and do everything
digitally
that means that the whole front end
that's mixing your signals
up to ku band or whatever none of your
software cares about that all it has to
do is have some enable lines that turn
things on and off some ones and zeros
here is in there
but from the point of view of the
software developer who's trying to
design something for company a or
company b
they don't care it's all agnostic it's
the exact same thing that they've used
before
because the software stays the same um
the other cool thing is the fpga um
they're a little bit more hard to
program than something in c
um they can take a little bit of time
but you need to run them in order to
have data rates of about 100 megabit per
second
but we're going to run this thing off of
the new radio so the people who want to
have lower data rates can just have
their flight cpus and their ground
stations running gnu radio
and sending information about the types
of waveforms that it wants
simulating it in the cpu over to the
radio
so the radio then doesn't have to do all
the synthesis of the waveform in fpga
programming in verilog or vhdl or
whatever it is that takes a long time
but again once you have a few software
routines you can recycle them from
design to design
so um yeah
so you see how we're able to leverage
off-the-shelf things i'm saying words
like fpga i'm saying words like analog
devices
yeah i know from now or later but
um so how so why did they say x-band
couldn't work and
how did you get around that
impossibility well by not knowing about
it
um things okay so x-band uh we're
talking the range of frequencies
around 8 to about 10 gigahertz right
um so that is like your phone
the highest frequency that um
your phone's worked out for the longest
period of time was l-band
and then uh so that's like i don't know
1.4 gigahertz or wherever it is that the
cell phone bands were
um and then and then they added the
wi-fi chips to phones so now
phones could talk at 2.4 gigahertz so
what happened when they when we added
wi-fi
as a global standard is that everybody
started making inexpensive chips for
s-band
so now 2.4 gigahertz which is still like
a lot of oscillations per second you're
talking you know
the electrons in your line or the
photons in space are flipping back and
forth
at gigahertz like that is really high
but we don't think of it as high anymore
because it's just become a standard
and so you i i promise i'm getting to uh
you're answering your question i'm just
going through a bit of history to
to punctuate it um
so companies with the smartest of people
analog and linear they've all they've
all thrown their best engineers this all
happened like 15 years ago that this
isn't
like you know right now people aren't
going wi-fi
you know this already this already
happened it came in and went well not
went
but we're going over to the five
gigahertz band soon anyway
so they made that band inexpensive that
means connectors for that band
amplifiers for that band circuit design
techniques are all known you go
to that that company's website and they
will have complete evaluation kits
for the correct design of a radio and
guess what if
if it's a good design for earth with
minor modifications it will work in
space
the things i went over before
and then and then recently the five
gigahertz ism band
became in use so now uh modern you know
ipads and everything they speak ymax
they speak at almost six gigahertz so
you're getting really really close to
x-band now and again
over the last five years companies have
been making amplifiers design techniques
transceiver modules
direct synthesis units and receivers and
forward error correction codes and the
whole software suite that is good for
that band
so at the time that we were trying to do
this like like
that had already happened but nobody was
yet doing really inexpensive stuff at
x-bands
probably the person who told my boss
that at whatever conference it was
he was maybe just about five years out
of date and hadn't realized
how much people had pushed forward into
six gigs
because guess what once you have six
gigahertz components with minor tweaks
or by finding sister units
you can make eight gigahertz components
so it's by
writing on the coattails of what
industry is doing already
is what made inexpensive small radios
possible at high frequencies in a
cubesat i doubt it could have really
been done
about 20 years ago but we were in a
sweet spot where it was possible
and same thing goes for for this new
design i'm doing as part of
bitbeam technologies it is
again leveraging chips a lot of them
have come out in the last year
so again the same design would not have
been possible three years ago
that also means that yeah you have a
bigger testing burden
you have to do environmental testing
radiation because these are brand new
cutting edge components
you know god only knows if they're going
to work up there but you can test
and you can save a lot of money by using
them
then answer your question good that
mostly silicon based soft nowadays or is
it
gallium or something yeah gallium a lot
of it yeah
the higher car emergency stuff
absolutely um
the uh the mcu's and stuff
are not um but the primal fires yeah
but even if you don't want to start your
own space company or you don't want to
innovate in that field there are other
ways to explore space
like there's hobby space you can start
talking to
radios they're already up there there's
a million cubesats up there that have
open radio formats
you can either just listen to uh packets
coming down from their satellite and
figure out what's happening maybe
they'll have some temperature data maybe
they'll have some pressure sensors
you can for example listen to the iss as
beacon
and these are mostly at the amateur
frequencies like 437 megahertz
and all you need is a rotor set a couple
of yagi antennas
this is a picture from a university of
strasbourg i don't know how to pronounce
them i i was not involved with this
at all and i didn't build this one but i
build a lot like it
um so i'm just using their picture
because it was a nice picture on the
internet
you can put together one of these ground
stations and start tracking your
satellites
almost immediately in about less than a
week after ordering the parts and
calibrating putting everything together
you can be talking to stuff in space
so that's a fun way to get into the
field also
but are you talking or just listening
um so i'm not sure if right now in this
instant there's any satellites you can
talk to
you can listen i know that there's one
going up in august that i have a radio
uh riding on we're going to release the
code open source
and so people can ping the satellite
they won't be able to send commands all
the way through
because that's that part's going to be
encrypted so there's no way they can get
out of the radio
and to the flight computer but they can
at least get to the radio and say
huh they can poke it go hey tell me
something what's your temperature
there's a there's a there's a
temperature sensor on the board and so
you can get that kind of information out
of it
so i know that will be available in
august and that will be an s-band unit
and so again a dish on the ground and a
set of yagi's
in a quiet area where there's not a lot
of wi-fi interference and you should be
able to talk to the satellite
yeah so basically the whole thesis here
is you ride on the coattails of what
people are moving into already
one or two people a small startup you
can't invent a whole new field
well sometimes you can um but
maybe i'm not that smart but i am smart
enough to use components
and and trends that other people have
done and just hook on to that
so what i see that analog devices has
released a new chip i'm always on
everybody's i'm subscribed to all of the
chip manufacturer's mailing list and i
go how can i use that
or maybe they've dropped the cost of a
design and so i start utilizing that
this kind of stuff works in space you
can use the
schematics that they give you on their
website change out the oscillators for
temperature compensated designs
shield everything excessively because if
you jam
your satellites receive channels with
your transmit lines or with your
data relays you will never be able to
reach your satellite
put in really good software protocols so
that you can't accidentally mess up the
image that the radios are running
put your receivers always in a safe
state have them always be on and always
listening at a low data rate if you want
to talk to it at a high data rate later
fine you can tell it to
go over temporarily to a higher data
rate or higher performance modulation
scheme
but have it default to something slow
and reliable that you can reach it from
just a set of yagi's
what else we've gone through temperature
use leaded solder
uh to prevent whiskering um use low loss
um pcbs uh so the top layer where your
actual rf signals are running let me go
back to this really quick
so these copper traces right here are
coplanar waveguide
that's a way to contain the electric
fields nicely different emi and also to
have low loss and
50 ohm lines they are basically seeing
the ground field that's on the top of
the board
and they're seeing the ground that's uh
between uh
the top and the second layer of your pcb
stack and you need to make sure the
dielectric that's in there is a low loss
material rogers 4000 series is really
great
it increases the cost of your boards but
again you can still get 16 boards come
back and
under 3 000 even using that do copper
fills everywhere a lot of vias
you want to have mounting holes for heat
spreaders because up there fans will not
work
because there is no air and so here you
can see these
bolt holes or mounting holes for an
aluminium plate to go underneath
aluminium is not as conductive as copper
so you might think well why would you
want to use aluminium instead of copper
as a heat spreader because down here we
might use copper for something high
performance
it turns out copper is a lot denser and
so aluminium is still a better choice
because
you'd rather pay a little bit of volume
to prevent the huge mass hit
so you just use a little bit more of it
and heat straps to the chassis and make
sure that wherever that heat strap is
going or the chassis of your spacecraft
is facing enough towards the cold part
of outer outer space
so it can radiate heat effectively it's
not going to radiate heat very
effectively towards the earth or towards
the sun
but it'll cast it out the rear and it's
pointing towards the cold stars
so by using all that kind of stuff and
keeping in mind you can right now
start designing electronics that will be
used in space
and with good probability they will work
you have to be responsible about how you
do it make sure you get the right
licenses
and make sure you can always maintain
control over your satellites so that in
case it's about to
go into contact with somebody else you
can help avoid that collision
i see this this recent trend of these
little postage stamp size satellites
that people are really
thrilled to assemble i'm not actually
sure that's very
uh ethically good in space because these
little postage stamps
they're almost untraceable they're just
scatter around like dust
and people can't control them or even
reliably talk to them
and they're just causing space debris
but in the next size up as long as you
can control and command your satellite i
think it's a great field to innovate in
and i'm done so let's do questions so
what happens when
things do collide um you get a lot more
pieces
and uh
did you see the movie gravity that's
what happened
so you guys have your hands clean you
haven't caused any big international
incidents
but nobody knows who mostly not
really a good thing for that question
then i'll i'll
get to that um every single object that
then
emanates as a new traceable piece of
debris and again i think the air force
or whoever it is whatever government
agency has the radars they can trace
everything that's
i don't know bigger than a couple of
postage stamps i don't know if we're
talking two inches or five inches across
but like
that small anything bigger than that
gets cataloged
it gets a catalog id it gets posted to
their website and it has a three line
element assigned to it a tle
that anybody then with a ground station
can use that tle plug it into a
propagation program figure out when it's
where and when it's going to be there
and so that means that every object then
after this collision gets tagged and
they're using all those objects
to predict future collisions i know the
air force is really sweating getting to
some smaller sizes too right now
because the smaller debris can cause
bigger pieces to
fall off of things bigger pieces become
smaller pieces
exactly um i'm thinking if you launch a
bowling ball into medium earth orbit
it's going to be there forever
but you're mostly going into low earth
orbit where there is a little bit of
drag
and the life expectancy of a satellite
varies with its mass to
drag ratio i would spend five years on
our in our
playing field in that sense i would
think that a small postage stamp like
thing
might flutter and drag and re-enter a
whole lot more
quickly than what people are normally
watching out for
that is correct so small uh extremely
small satellites
including these supposed to stamp things
they will reenter quite quickly and so
they're not a dangerous thing to stay up
forever
um it's um it's that amount of
remember the numbers many slides back
showing the amount of kinetic energy and
potential energy you have to deliver per
kilogram to get up there well the drag
forces are proportional to your cross
section
your drag cross section so if you have a
long skinny extremely
heavy satellite and you can always keep
it so that its cross-section is just the
front of
the cross-section of the skinny side
it's going to be up there for a long
time
if you have like a big sheet or
something and you rotate it
so that the whole sheet is a sale
against all the particles up there it's
going to re-enter really quickly
what about software for communications
and robotics and also for
re-entry as well too um
yeah so software for uh robotics
real time yeah you want to do something
like uh manipulation of something
oh okay yeah um let's see um
we have done we have done some tests i'd
say that
qualifies that okay so i can speak
generally about that
having not built an exact robot with
grasping things but satellites are kind
of robots
that's where the zero g questions come
yeah so the software particles
uh to command your satellite um you want
things like important data to continue
to be sent until it is acknowledged
you need to have the appropriate data
rate
for the links so that you can get enough
data back
so that you can give intelligent
commands up to your satellite
so if you need to crank up your data
rates of your radio links to get a lot
of telemetry if you're doing some big
active
manipulation then you have to do that
you need to support that link
a lot of times for really really fast
stuff the ground
can't actually command the satellite
fast enough to do stuff
at spacex for
for the rockets they were fairly
self-sustained
um and and most of these um
most of these things are making
decisions on their own for a lot of
things just like um
fighter jets like the person kind of
tells the fighter jet to point left but
it's the computer over there that's
doing all the fast control loops and
actually
you know figuring out how much you know
forced to allocate to every thruster
same thing with satellites they they
have to have a lot of built-in knowledge
and rockets also in order to be fairly
self-sustained you just kind of
point them in the general right
direction but you often can't reach them
fast enough with the huge latencies in
order to tell them what to do on a
minute by minute level
it's going to be an interesting thing
when we are when we're going to have
like
robot grasping arms that we're going to
want to control from
the earth and we're going to have to
deal with that propagation time when
we're telling the robot arm what to do
um i'm not sure of a good way to get
around
special relativity there you're kind of
limited
um right now on the iss i don't know
where that stands though
they're probably controlling it locally
from the iss they're doing both
um what about also reentering the issue
of you want to return
something from your your nano set uh-huh
as an example
so a friend of mine did this the spacex
heat shield
as an example but how do you guys look
at control software for re-entries and
things like that
um yeah so to re-enter you want to
increase your drag
um and so you want to be able to
control uh so you can do it two ways you
can either reduce your velocity
so if you have some sort of active
thruster you can either do a plasma
thruster
or you can do an actual can of some sort
of compressed gas either flammable or
non-flammable
you can fire in the in the wrong
direction opposite to the direction
you're going and you can
drop down fairly quickly or you can
rotate your satellite
by playing um with your position by just
rotating yourself around and you can do
that by playing with magnetic fields by
pushing off of them
by basically having coils in different
directions you just kind of nudge
yourself
into a different orientation
various companies are yeah um
yes i was wondering the more general
case the early cubesats i knew about
they kind of tumbled
and did what they would and there wasn't
a whole lot of attitude control
and there wasn't a whole lot of thrust
available to it
um how far has that advanced what you
mentioned
making sure your heat radiators were
pointing to the cold stars
how much control do you have and how is
that done
and if you are on a collision course
with another satellite
how much control do you have to what do
you do with that information
um so uh in terms of so
the first question is how do you
maintain
a correct pointing of a small satellite
and
you need to do the analysis of your
moment
so how much mass you have far away from
your center
and that that tells you how much force
you need to exert in order to rotate
around all your various axes
um a common technology that's used there
uh there's two different ones one are
plasma thrusters and the other ones are
magnetworkers
there are off-the-shelf components being
sold at all of the nano
satellite conferences like at smallsat
and utah this year
you can just get these things they're
not cheap but you can just buy them and
pop them into your satellite
and you need uh you know enough to make
sure you can rotate over every axis
you also can store
up energy by spinning up something on
the inside
and then de-de-power the spinning thing
by using energy off of your solar panels
so that was the first question how you
maintain pointing the second
one was avoiding collisions
right i don't know exactly how much
delta v
you can give i haven't done the analysis
not being a gnc engineer myself i mostly
focus on the radios but
i do know that you get notification from
the air force
a long time in advance typically it's
like your first
email about the eminent collision will
be something a week out
and of course in a week a lot of things
change and if you actually take action
immediately
a very very small amount of delta v is
enough to just completely change your
cones
in opposite directions so if either or
the other party just does a little bit
of a zap with a plasma thruster
or just increases their dread their drag
a little bit
they will get out of danger of course
they're
little one-inch firecrackers on the
outside you could
um i don't recommend that particular
design um
but i think physically it should work
yeah um well okay i
actually uh he raised a second question
which was
you you've added some delta v so now
you've changed your um
your triplet whatever it's called and
now you're aimed towards somebody else
how dense is it
um up there yeah um let's see
uh you'll get a couple of notifications
a year for one satellite uh in a couple
of years
maybe one or two way to go to try and to
minimize the chance that you're not
hitting him but you're hitting him
instead
yeah you know i don't know what the
mental process is uh so
so the question was um you know you're
on eminent collision course with person
a
but how do you make sure that you don't
change your course and hit five other
people who are also sharing an orbit
with you
i'm not sure how you would do that you
probably would stay
in your orbit more or less you would
just go a little bit forward or back
along it so basically by just
increasing your velocity a little bit
you can just increase the altitude of
your orbit just
a little bit and mostly just kind of
stay in the same direction you probably
don't want to change your course
completely and go sideways
a because your business model probably
isn't for that other orbit you probably
put your satellite where you wanted it
and so you just change it a little bit
i don't know if i've never seen in the
emails the air force gives you any sort
of
planned maneuver but you'd probably just
get on your computer you'd run the three
line elements for you and everybody else
of of interest
most importantly obviously the station
which which actually has people in it
that that's your most important
consideration to make sure you don't go
into that orbit directly
and plan out a new route
other than remote sensing what is the
business model
communications so
there is an interesting project
they yeah it's it's all public it's on
their website i can pull it up
called for example
outernet let's do a google search now i
can't connect to the internet oh well
um i guess the wi-fi doesn't work down
here they're trying to do
free um free
media from space like you know wikipedia
and things like that for countries which
may have blocked access to that
so that's that's kind of a
not-for-profit model of somebody who's
trying to do something cool in that
space
you have planet labs which is during
earth observation so
actual uh high cadence a
very very low latency images of the
earth so
in case something interesting happens
you can actually just check the
photographs that were taken five or six
hours maybe at most 24 hours ago of that
region versus like
landsat and other you know imaging
satellites of you know maybe 10 or 15
years ago you had to
call up the company or get an rfq on
their website
and you issue a check for 40 000 or
however much it costs and
they plan it and on the next satellite
pass they will slew their entire
satellite and take an amazing immaculate
extremely high resolution shot of that
exact teeny tiny space that you wanted
but it's certainly not the whole world
being updated on a daily basis
so communications observation ship
tracking
airplane tracking
you can do a lot with sensing uh
weather weather satellites are also the
us
ran out of funding to replace the two
weather satellites that it has during
north america right now so we're just
gonna kind of be without
weather coverage in a couple of years in
california we'll be okay but i was in
alaska recently and those people are
like freaking out they're like people
are gonna start dying
in alaska you know somebody who drove
out to do some winter
fishing in a pond without that you know
low latency weather data for alaska
people are just going to freeze in their
trucks
and so that's another thing that we can
get in is replace those weather
satellites with small
agile spacecraft and there's more
this might get you way off track so
maybe you'd rather defer until after the
camera turns off but
in your biography on the class website
you mentioned
standing on the deck of a ship and the
pacific catching bits coming down from a
falling satellite
yes it's impossible not to wonder what
that's all about
yeah so this was um falcon 1
uh flight 4. 4 for spacex
we had never had a successful launch
before
but they placed a couple of us on a flat
bottomed
military barge so she's like a container
ship she's got a big bridge
and like a big flat end with a crane and
you can lift stuff
conveniently like maybe a rocket chassis
that comes back
and they sent us out to um
so you have kwajalein
is like down here near indonesia
somewhere you have hawaii up here and
you have california over here
and so the rocket was going to launch
this way
and it's got your different stages and
the front end with the payload in it
they had us motor out in a boat into the
middle of the pacific ocean
so here we are with our little flat
bottom military barge
and um there was an impact zone
somewhere in the pacific ocean
and this impact zone was this huge
compromise between the quadrillion range
services
and spacex we had our own analysis that
said well the impact is going to be
right here and they said well no but our
analysis shows it's going to be right
here
and so a lot of hemming and hawing and
back and forthing uh we were placed
uh somewhere outside of some compromise
of those two boxes but just outside
you want to be fairly close so you can
get the data
as its stream down but not so close to
you have a probability of being hit
so anyway so the barge parked itself
outside of this big
expected impact zone and uh there was
stage separation that happened over that
so these two uh this one shuts off
its ignition they separate
these two continue on so the second
stage in the fairing they continue on to
orbit
and this thing starts falling in a
parabolic arc and
elon is all about doing recyclable
components
and so we were trying to get data from
that first stage
to see how it would do i can't tell you
anything about the results or the
or really anything else except that we
had a dish
and we were pointing it at the satellite
and we were getting the radio link
more than six degrees you say wait wait
that one's not ours
um yeah uh we could see it with the bear
um just barely but we could we could see
it in the distance
um but we had practiced it a lot and uh
there was more complex stuff
going on than just by hand but i can't
tell you what the technology we used was
obviously
but yeah we basically just pointed the
dish at the rocket as it went by and we
got data from it
and then able to analyze it later
when you talked about the postage stamp
guys how are they getting deployed
they just jam a bunch of them into one
of these pea pods and just spray them
out or
that's a good question i don't know how
the poster stamps are being deployed
i have no idea hmm um i think there is
some sort of fairly open
source project or some sort of open
collaboration so you should be able to
find it on
on the internet figure out how they're
doing that
obviously getting up to orbit is fairly
cheap because their weight
is nothing you know they're like maybe
an ounce or two
so um yeah i don't know what the
deployment is like
hopefully it's good
you